vous avez vous balader sur deux jambes
cassées depuis plusieurs semaines que
j'y retourne quand la prochaine fois que
vous sauter vos avances pulvérisé il ya
plein d'autres façons de servir son pays
tu fais quoi déjà tu as dit je pose
comme un analyste au département d'état
safa timide
pourquoi voulez vous intégrer la cia
je voudrais contribuer au rayonnement de
mon pays dans le monde la durée moyenne
de ce test est de 5 heures j'ai terminé
au bout de 40 minutes je fais quoi
maintenant ce que vous voulez le
directeur adjoint de la nasa
marie proposait un nouveau poste si on
pourrait en dire plus non comme tu sais
trouver l'éguille terroriste dans la
meule de foin d'internet de prêts à
passer à l'action
celui-là maire christian attend comment
c'est possible si tu veux ça fonctionne
comme google sauf que ça cherche pas
seulement dans ce que les gens en public
donc daily mail chat sms tout ce qu'on
veut épouser mon fils qui je comprends
pas
tout le royaume blanche neige la nsa a
placé sous surveillance tous les
portables du monde les américains ne
rêve pas d'être libre ce qu'ils veulent
c'est la sécurité oui ce fut
malheureusement les gens ignorent qu'ils
sont passées à marcher le surveille
il se passe au sein du gouvernement des
choses vraiment grave et je ne peux pas
faire comme si de rien n'était
tout ce que j'ai et là dessus ils ont
vite fait de découvrir tout ce que j'ai
fait
avez vous utilisé un logiciel pour
lequel vous n'aviez pas d'autorisation
tu risques quand même la peine de mort
non de dieu les autorités savent qu'on a
c'est donc d'humour
il a plus de temps à perdre et on s'en
prendre à moi et il faut s'en prendre
aux civils
imovie pour le temps que tu as
les
le travail
une confiture